bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau rugby nerfs le numéro 14
est aujourd'hui nous allons continuer
avec des exemples de graphiques avancés
dont j'espère que vous allez bien on
jette dans la poursuite de la cession de
la semaine dernière au royaume à
différents trucs et astuces et vous
voyant voir comme moi ce qu'on peut tous
mobilisés afin de pouvoir réaliser ces
graphiques
la première chose qu'on va faire je j'ai
préparé j'ai déjà préparé en fait
répertoire travail pour aujourd'hui mais
pour pouvoir avancer on va les récupérer
les données qui vont servir d'exemple
d'aujourd'hui donc je vous invite comme
toujours aller sur le site des
webinaires vous avez le menu séance tout
en haut qui permet de voir toutes les
séances
on va aller sur la cession du jour
exemple de graphiques avancés deux et on
va les récupérer le fichier bande
dessinée tintin pour excéder 6 donc je
vais le télécharger et ce que je vais
faire je vais aller l'orangé dans
documents mais binaire 14 c'est ma
session du chevaux et j'enregistre du
coup mon fichier là à portée de main
donc j'avais déjà fait avant vous
arriviez donc un nouveau répertoire de
travail donc un nouveau projet studio et
donc du coup de dent nous avons
maintenant d'autres fichiers de données
tintin points et c'est l'axé alors je
vais vous présenter rapidement des
données qui vont vous avez aujourd'hui
un là en fait je veux utiliser des
données qui sont complètement fictive
alors du mois sont générés à partir de
données réelles mais qui n'ont aucun
rapport et donc l'idée c'est que les
données qu'on a aujourd'hui
elles proviennent de la situation dans
les années 50 au sortir de la guerre et
on a deux pays la syldavie et la
bordurie
pour votre culture ce sont 2 bis inventé
par hergé et donc ces deux pays ont
décidé de mettre en place un vaste
programme de distribution de bandes
dessinées de tintin dans les écoles et
dans les collèges afin de motiver des
élèves à la lecture est donc dans les
deux pays on a envoyé des agents
dispensateur qui vont distribuer des
agents qui sont en charge de distribuer
ces bandes dessinées dans les élèves
auprès des élèves et des collégiens et
donc nous disposons du rapport
d'activités les différents agents et ses
rapports d'activité vindicte par mois ou
qu'ils ont rempli une fiche par mois et
par type d'établissement le nombre
d'élèves qu'ils ont rencontrées et puis
le nombre de bons dessinée qui les ont
distribués
alors on va déjà commencer par on va
faire un nouveau script mer
donc on va s'occuper du ch déjà du
chargement des données
alors pour aujourd'hui comme toujours on
va chercher le tailles diverses
ça fait partie de nos package de base
et puis on va aller importer les données
et donc pour ça elle son format excel
donc on veut utiliser le web etc salle
chargeant ceux ci et puis si on se
souvient plus de la commande qui nous
permet de charger nous d'en dessiner est
bon on peut toujours aller dans l'onglet
environnement eau alors de le faire
réapparaître
vous avez ici une pente à tassette je
vais faire forme excellent l'art
l'occurrence donc je vais chercher vous
fichier local dans dessinée tintin mais
je vais en faire un objet d un peu plus
court dont je la paie sa bd
héricy bien que mais variables sont
correctement importé que l'option fausse
3d m5 la première ligue mondiale non des
variables et bien cochée et je vais
cliquez sur une bourde
l'arrangement cliquez sur une porte sam
a réalisé le code voir ce qui
m'intéresse un set plutôt de pouvoir
copiez ce code
on va refaire la manipulation il me
porte à cette fois macky sall c'est le
fichier bande dessinée je vais en faire
un objet qui s'appelle bd et là j'avais
simplement cliquer sur le petit bouton
ici copier et on va fermer ça et je vais
pouvoir copier mon code là où j'en ai
besoin
alors vous savez déjà ce live le wimax à
l ue
bdc pour pouvoir voir le fichier
réalisée à la fin je n'ai pas besoin
dans mon code générique
et puis je vais penser à sauvegarder le
code du jour script du binaire 14 alors
maintenant on va reprendre le ton quand
même de regarder se fiche là je clique
rapidement donc les datas vous voyez on
a une première variable qui contient
l'année une deuxième variable qui
contient le mois ces deux variables sont
rentrés sous forme numérique
c'est ensuite une variable qui contient
le pays une variable qui contient le
type d'établissement et puis dont deux
indicateurs le nombre d'élèves
rencontrés et le nombre de bd est
distribuée qu'il faut retenir c'est que
les données étaient rentrés par
plusieurs agents donc je dois avoir pour
un même pays pour un même endroit un
plusieurs observations pour janvier 1950
alors ce que j'aimerais voir c'est
comment évolue finalement le nombre de
bons dessinée qui sont distribués par
mois
alors sauf que si je regarde variable
année mais donner elle commence en 1949
j'ai un minimum en 1949 et se termine en
1950 est une donc là je n'ai pas une
variable qui m'indique le mois de
l'année puisque si j'ai moins c'est 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
sauf que j'aimerais bien distinguer et
bien décembre 1952 décembre 1949 ce
qu'on va faire on va donc créer une
variable de type date est ce que je vais
faire puisque là en fait j'ai des points
qui correspond en fait à des mois
entiers les simplement considéré que
toutes les données du mois de janvier je
veux les appliquer au 1er janvier
alors pour manipuler les dates le plus
simple c'est d'avoir un recours au
package le breeders du taille diverse
que je vais charger parce qu'il n'est
pas chargé par défaut même s'il
appartient au package le bord des routes
a dit à l'ensemble du tailles diverses
on reviendra sur ce package 1dans dont
les prochaines dans les prochaines
séances
parce que c'est vraiment l'élément de
référence qu'on va essayer de faire pour
moment c'est créer la date sous un
format textuelle et donc du coup ce que
je vais faire je vais coller ensemble
différentes informations non pour coller
des chaînes de caractères ensemble on
peut avoir recours à astres et la
fonction de base dans l'air ou alors on
peut utiliser str6 du package string et
je me rappelle stringer c'est le paquet
de manipulation du texte dans le tag
diverses
alors si je fait tester rc de bd à nice
kir sbd moi tu irais 0 1
juste pour face à cette commande là vous
voyez ce que j'obtiens c'est une chaîne
de textes 1 qui contient l'année le tir
est le mois le tirait le jour
normalement jusqu ici ça devrait être à
peu près bon est ce que je veux faire je
veux transformer ça en une date
donc là je suis sous un format année
mois jour hier membres des et dans ce
cas là je peux utiliser la fonction y md
du package
le bridge est donc la fonction y amène
dl permet de convertir une date sous la
forme année mois jour un objet de type
date
peu importe vous utilisez des tirets ou
des slash 1 pour séparer y mde va se
débrouiller si vous aviez une date souk
est au format à l'américaine
c'est-à-dire moins par jour bar année
vous auriez divisé m d y est si vous
aviez une date stockées en forme à la
française c'est à dire moi barre par
jour
bach mois par année vous auriez teasé
mdm igac on va refaire quelques exemples
vous avez ici dans ce format là non là
les dates ont bien été détectée est ce
que j'obtiens un c'est un objet de type
date que je vais faire on va le
sauvegarder 1dans bd je vais appeler ça
date donc un bep des dates ici je prends
année je colle dirais-je comme moi je
colle 0,1 et je dis que c'est au format
année mois jours et ce que j'obtiens un
certain objet de ti
date si je fais classe de bep des dates
juillet j'obtienne date une manière
alternative de faire la même chose ça
aurait été éventuellement de se la faire
à la française avec 0 1 puis le mois
puis l'année donc pour vous montrer en
si je fais cette commande là je veux
tenir une chaîne de textes qui sous la
forme jour bar - par année et pour la
convertir en date
j'aurais juste à utiliser des m y donc
des membres hier en fait et on arrive au
même résultat si vous montre bd date on
obtient exactement la même chose
là vous avez dans les deux cas ça va
être transformé par défaut mais
représentent toujours les dates sous la
forme année ti pour retenez à
l'importance du format hannity rémois
tirer jour c'est que quand vous mettez
le jour où le mot en premier il ya
toujours une confusion possible entre le
format l'américaine qui est moi journée
et le format la française qui est jour -
année alors que quand on commence par
l'année il n'y a pas de confusion
possible on est sur la forme anne et moi
jours l'autre avantage c'est que si je
vais vous le transformer en texte et
vous fait un tri ace à betty kéba votre
trio soviétique quand vous êtes au
format année mois jour est également un
tri chronologique donc retenir cet asus
là quand par exemple ou nommer des
fichiers voulait mettre des numéros de
verse une date de version par exemple
vous n'êtes pas mon article version du 8
avril
mettez vais à 2021 1-0 4-0 8 et du conte
mettant l'état dans votre fichier sous
cette forme année - jour dans votre
navigateur
aux dates vos fichiers alphabétiques
mans seront triossi chronologiquement
j'ai donc maintenant une variable tâte
et donc on va pouvoir faire assez
facilement
notre premier graphique donc notre
graphique on va commencer
ça va être ggp lot de bd donc moi ce que
je veux représenter c'est le nombre de
bandes dessinées distribué par mois donc
on fait on va additionner tout ça je
l'utilisé du coût des bars par des fous
la jolie bar utilise la statistique
tantes qui va additionner les éléments
et donc je vais simplement indiqué à rs
x légal date
alors petite précision pour bien
comprendre si je fais juste à metz fixe
égale date et que je fais j'aime barre
mon graphique ne sera pas encore
parce que par défaut chaque ligne
d'observation va être content et une
seule fois or si vous vous rappelez dans
notre tableau on sur satanique
d'observation il y avait 5 il y avait 5
bd distribués sur d'autres choses avec
un 20 sur 20 ou tout ce qu'on veut c'est
le pas le nombre de rapports mais c'est
bien le nombre de bandes dessinées
distribué donc en fait chaque ligne
compte pour un nombre de bandes
dessinées et donc du coup il faut que le
calcul se fasse en pondérant les lignes
par le nom de bande dessinée donc je
vais indiquer waits et galbées dé
distribuer et à ce moment là
chacune de mes observations sera pondéré
par le nombre d'observations et je veux
bien obtenir ce que je veux comme est
donné ce sont sur des pentes à moi en
fait ce que vous avez c'est bien une
barre par mois et bien comme on a fourni
non pas à des mois mais un vrai objet
date
ggp lotz égérie du coup mon accès 6
comme un axe temporel
enfin on peut essayer d'améliorer un
tout petit peu graphique qui
m'intéresserait c'est aussi de voir le
volume distribué en fonction du type
d'établissement et donc on peut
améliorer ça en rajoutant fils et cal
type établissements et donc je
directement le graphique avec les types
d'établissements ce qu'on voit c'est que
c'est un petit peu dur à lire parce que
notre légende sur la droite prend pas
mal de place je vais donc tout
simplement la déplacer en dessous donc
tu aimes les djeunes position légale
bottom celui-ci on l'a déjà vu plusieurs
points c'est vraiment celui à connaître
par coeur
voilà donc on a maintenant la légende en
dessous c'est un petit peu plus facile à
lire
et puis donc on retrouvera les mêmes
part que tout à l'heure c'est juste que
la colorisation s'est faite par partie
d'établissement et donc on voit qu'il ya
eu une augmentation de distribution au
premier semestre 1951 creux au niveau de
l'été puis ça a redémarré au début là on
doit être en janvier 1951 donc la cds
sans 1950 et novembre vous voyez il ya
eu un creux pendant l'été et la reprise
et puis voyez le programme a monté de
manière assez importante dans la suite
par contre ce que j'ai ici c'est deux
pays
donc j'aimerais autant avoir un
graphique qui me présente mes deux pays
et bien comme tout est calculé à la
volée c'est assez facile on a juste
besoin de rajouter des facettes
donc je vais rajouter un facettes grid
donc là j'aimerais avoir deux graphiques
côte-à-côte donc du coup je vais
appliquer une variable sur les colonnes
donc cause
je dois les appeler avec verve et la
variable qui va me servir ces pays et en
faisant ça fait maintenant deux
graphiques côte à côte un pour la bombe
comme pour la syldavie ce qui me permet
de comparer un petit peu les deux et on
voit bien le clou peu le creux ici hein
il est vraiment différent bordurie et la
syldavie une autre manière de
représenter les deux pays si je veux pas
comparer dans les volumes et je veux
plutôt voir la dynamique entre les deux
j'aurais pu plutôt les mettre en ligne
avec un run en faisant ça j'ai réussi
deux graphiques l'un au dessus de
l'autre et surtout ça permet de plus
facilement repart il avait deux
temporalités
vous voyez donc sur ce graphique je vais
beaucoup mieux voir donc tout dépend si
ebuya met l'accent plutôt sur les
volumes et comparer les volumes entre
les deux pays ou si vous voulez plutôt
mettre l'accent sur la temporalité et
parce qu'effectivement là on voit
beaucoup mieux les différents ce timing
en émettant l'un au dessus de l'autre
alors on peut avoir envie d'améliorer un
petit peu notre notre graphique
donc là on va commencer à voir une série
d'astuces pour rendre le graphique un
petit peu plus vivant et visible
la première chose c'est voyez j'ai ici à
un axe dx qui est tout en bas et je me
dis ça serait peut-être bien de pouvoir
leur répéter ici pour qu'on ait quelque
chose de plus lisible donc une manière
de répéter un axe peut pas le faire
nativement avec les pelotes 2 mais il ya
un package qui fournissent à et qui
s'appelle le package lemon donc je vais
rajouter le package lemon alors on va
améliorer un tout petit peu on va battre
a besoin d'un titre pour certains de
parties donc ça c'est le nom de bd
distribué par mois maintenant je
le package les mains dispose de facet
rep grid c'est la même chose que
d'autres facettes
sauf que cette version face est très
bien qu'ils aient fourni par les modes
permet de répéter notre axe vous voyez
bien comment se trouve il n'y a pas du
tout dax dessinée ans aussi je fais ceci
mon axe va être redessinés alors pour le
moment on voit que les petites marques
qui sont dessinés et si j'aimerais
répéter aussi les étiquettes je peux
mettre la fonction huit pistes cyclables
et je vais passer cette option là à chew
pour indiquer que je vais aussi répété
les étiquettes de valeur sur mon mac
pendant que lemon fourni façade floride
effaçait très pop qui sont vraiment
d'équivalent de facet bolide à cette
frappe
simplement ça permet de pouvoir répéter
les alors on va aller un petit peu plus
loin vous l'avez vu j'aime bien en tant
que faire se peut essayer d'alléger un
petit peu les graphiques
quand on a pas besoin d'en mettre plus
que nécessaire et donc pour ça on l'a vu
on peut utiliser différents types de
thèmes on avait déjà vu certains thèmes
comme
thème clean a par exemple dernière fois
sachez qu'il ya certes un package qui
proposait tellement plus notamment c'est
le cas de ge est donc si je cherche gg
thème sur cran va nous ramener sur la
page du package
j'ai du coup le lien du site de
documentation donc là on est sur le
dépôt git hub avec le code du package et
voyez il ya un site plus complet qui
poursuit propose ici à droite
donc si je l'ouvrais avoir un site de
documentation qui doit être en train de
se charger alors dans le monde est censé
avoir des preview des thèmes
je vois qu'il ya un petit souci mais si
on regarde ça propose différents types
de thèmes
d'accord vous avez un thème excellent et
là vous avez un exemple du résultat
obtenu avec ce thème excellent et donc
vous pouvez rechercher en différé ceux
qui sont proposés vous avez aussi un
thème du feu qui a un thème relativement
léger et vous avez celui qui va
m'intéresser
aujourd'hui c'est thème clean il ya un
thème plutôt sobre 1 qui permet d'avoir
quelque chose d'un peu plus léger donc
si je veux utiliser ce thème là dans mon
code en supposant que vous ayez déjà un
installé le package et gtm j'avais
chargé j'ai en mémoire
est appelé
clean alors voyez là j'ai appelé mon
thème clean après avoir fait un thème
les djeunes position gaz bottom et je
les ai perdus il ya quelque chose qui
est important c'est que quand on appelle
un thème complet c'est mme clinton
correct m minimum
en fait ils redéfinissent tout le thème
donc en fait si on veut nous avoir des
personnalisations individuel que l'on
fait directement via la fonction time 1
il vaut mieux les mettre
après l'appel au thème générique je vais
déplacer mon thème des jeunes position'
bottom et maintenant je vais avoir du
coup ma légende en dessous alors le
graphique il est un petit peu petit la
lie parce que gérer à petit c'est mon
écran mais on verra que les tailles de
caractères ça se génère plutôt sur la
fin alors je peux aussi bas alléger un
petit peu plus ce graphique j'ai pas
forcément besoin de toutes ces
étiquettes l'ag des dates donc ça
devrait être à peu près explicite ce
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de
représenter là je vais mettre un titre
après qu'il ira que je représente le
nombre total donc j'ai pas besoin de
garder craintes sur les axes des ziks et
d y donc on va avec la fonction de l'abs
nettoyer un petit peu le graphique
et puis pareil collèges et écoles
primaires c'est explicite donc pas
besoin de rajouter l'avons le titre d'un
donc là nous avons
un graphique et un petit peu plus
allégée et puis éventuellement je vais
rajouter un titre donc là c'est nombre
de bandes dessinées distribuées chaque
mois
alors oui j'ai un titre qui était un
petit peu long je peux y mettre un terme
en titre sur deux lignes 1 et pour
mettre un petit sur deux lignes je vous
rappelle que le caractère retour à la
ligne quand on le sert van uhm est
annoncée en tissage haine anti cela joue
l'obtenait avec l'afrique touche
alger 8 sur un pc sous un bac vous
trouvez où se trouve le caractère et si
je mets un anti tâche n dans mon titre
voyez à l'androgynie monteith là j'ai un
retour à la ligne vraiment retenez un
anti sa chaîne
ce caractère retour à la ligne tout
comme la dernière fois on avait passé
pas mal de temps à discuter 1,2 du choix
d'une dune d'une palette de couleurs
pour avoir des couleurs qui sont un peu
qui contraste bien des couleurs qui sont
lentement compatible avec les personnes
qui sont qui sont daltonienne color
blindness en anglais et donc du coup moi
je vous avais dire une queue utilisé
assez souvent c'était finalement les
palettes de couleurs développé par paul
toll qui sont disponibles via le package
khroma donc on va charger khroma d'envoi
en profiter pour améliorer la palette de
couleurs donc c'est en scale fils est là
pour avoir la palette ce classique c'est
la palette bright un de paul tonnes
donc là on récupère une palette est par
défaut ça nous met à l'aise en bleu que
le primaire où je ne pose pas vraiment
de problème c'est que c'est visible et
ses contrastes et donc gardons cela
comme ça alors maintenant ça serait
quand même bien d'essayer d'améliorer un
petit peu la présentation notre axe dx
et là on est sur un axe avec des dates
alors vous voyez par défaut ici il nous
a mis à nu dirais moi donc ça le par
défaut en fait ça dépend de votre niveau
quand vous êtes uniquement sur quelques
jours ou juste trop quatre jours on
aurait eu un détail avec la date du jour
là on n'a mis que les mois passent que
parce que du coup on était sur une
période plus longue mais quand on veut
contrôler finement à neutre notre notre
axe
on va pouvoir avoir recours à une
fonction ce qu'il sait des fonctions des
chaînes x parce que c'est l'axé 6 et en
en a un qui s'appelle date qui nous
fournit du coût des options
supplémentaires pour les dates et pour
les connaître
comme toujours on peut regarder le
fichier dette
il y en a deux en particulier qui vous
intéressait le premier ces dates break
date brakes à nous permettre de dire à
quelle on le pas de temps qu'on veut
utiliser pour faire des coupures et
l'intérêt c'est que date brakes on va
pouvoir y donner les informations sous
la forme par exemple tweaks or tanière
c'est à dire on va pouvoir les donner
l'information textuelle et explicite et
lui va s'occuper de faire un calcul sur
les dates parce que entre les dates les
semaines les mois et moi 31 jours les
mois de 28 jours c'est souvent un peu
compliqué donc là ce que je vais
rajouter ces dates pour aix je vous
remontre graphique actuellement là par
défaut on sait à peu près tous les six
mois
évidemment je veux dire freemind pour
dire que j'aimerais bien avoir une
étiquette tous les trois mois donc
et ya tué trois mois alors par contre on
voit qui nous a représentés maintenant
sous la forme
anne et moi joe est un petit peu plus
difficile à lire est ce qu'on va faire
on va voir au cours à un autre est un
autre élément qui est intéressant qui
est non pas le label ce classique
meeddat label qui permet d'indiquer
comment mettre en forme les dates
tiers de code qui sont faites très court
en informatique et qui sont en fait
défini dans à l'aide de la fonction sprf
times donc ça c'est ce qui explique
aussi comment est ce qu'on met en forme
à des dates un de manière générique
il faut savoir que pour mettre en forme
à des tattes il ya des codes qui sont ce
qu'on appelle le posix standards
utilisés par par beaucoup de de software
et c'est vraiment très un standard très
international et vous avez une série de
codes sous la forme pourcentage à
miniscule humaine ou majuscule par
exemple pourcentage à majuscule c'est
ulrich des nems
donc si je m'étais ici tu as tu là bas
ce pourcentage à san afficherait en fait
le nom de la semaine nous ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est plutôt des fichiers
l'année alors vous avez pourcentage b
qui permet d'avoir le new abrégée du
mois ou pourcentage granby le nom
complet donc et puis l'année est stockée
avec y
vous avez y minuscule alors y minuscule
seuil est à wipeout suntory donc c'est
juste les deux dernières années sur deux
chiffres et grant y/y gspc d'année sur
quelques chiffres jeu donc on va faire
un exemple supposons que je veux le mois
abrégé et l'année sur deux chiffes
pourcentage y est je veux séparer les
deux avec un tir est donc en fait on
tape le texte à condren le représenter
et enlever les pourcentages mais aux
stages y là où on souhaite avoir le
rendu est là vous avez janvier tirer 50
si j'avais voulu mettre plutôt une barre
oblique entre les deux jeux
en fait je change le pattern il va se
représenter alors mettre le nez sur deux
jours c'est pas toujours ce qu'il ya de
plus intéressant parce que j'aimerais
mettre c'est plutôt l'année sur quatre
shift plus explicite mais voyez ça fait
des tic est un petit peu large
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire c'est
éventuellement faire des retours à la
ligne donc je l'utilisé qu'on avait déjà
vu long qui slash n est donc là vous
avez le mois retourne la ligne l'a dit
sur quelques chiffres
donc on a quelque chose qui est
relativement explicite petite précision
quand vous avez des jours de la semaine
où les noms de moi c'est toujours dans
la langue de votre système
d'exploitation donc moi je suis sur un
pc qui est en français vous avez ici les
résultats en français on peut changer la
langue utilisée mais c'est pas si facile
alors je vais essayer de retrouver la
commande locales m 6
donc la faune
utiliser ses 6,7 locale la catégorie est
alors je me trompe pas c'est elle c'est
regarder l'aide de cette fonction
puisque je me souviens jamais c'est un
peu toujours un peu compliqué les
questions de ce qu'en fait c'est lié par
cette mutation donc à la catégorie je
vais juste modifié ce qu on appelle l
sentheim c'est à dire le temps et je
crois que il suffit de mettre alors je
suis sous windows ou être simplement une
lettre à l'aiea d'avoir marché et si je
refais mon graphique
oui on
glay un loyer c'est ces gens comme
janvier mais à pair comme et priaulx
doulaye donc cela vous avez si je vous l
ai moins en entier le ferai encore plus
lisible
donc là on est déjà nous agrippe le 12
octobre johnny weir il july si je veux
passer en français c'est système guette
locale frêche
donc là il va trouver le français en
france alors ça ça marche sur sur
windows et sous linux ou mac
si ça ne marche pas il faudrait essayer
éventuellement le anyways quelque chose
comme ça voilà donc on peut le faire
c'est pas toujours si évident alors je
reviens à mon graphique
je vais revenir
je
embrouillé doute pas à la place de
riches alors je suis revenu à mon
graphique 1
donc avec les raccourcis on est revenu
sur le français je vois dans le chat qui
a une question qui elle peut tout
changer l'emplacement du non-dit pis
pour les placer à l'horizontale en haut
de chaque graphique pas de manière
facile pour en faire un
l'idée vous avez là on est
fondamentalement donc
donc on est sur une phase est d'accord
donc laissons positionné sur le côté il
faudrait que je modifie la position de
mai alors déjà il faudrait qu on les
déplace sur la gauche ce qui doit
pouvoir se faire si je me trompe pas
dans ça fait le retour mouvoir l'aide de
à cette grid à ces switchs coin by
default zola
artistes line up on the right of the
creative x alors juste pour essayer en
si je fais un switch légal beau mais
vraiment mon code universel entre up
alors oui par an ce qui l'est moins
c'est que tout à l'heure j'ai fait des
bêtises up alors remettons coop d'aplomb
donc si j'aurais exécute sa swt ch au
cochon ça aboie attendait donc switch
paille des choses à la base irrigue le
top label alors on va rester ici je
switche y donc ans
ansa d'accord j'ai racheté le switch
j'ai déplacé syldavie bordurie sur la
gauche
maintenant il va falloir jongler avec ce
thème là où ça va se compliquer un petit
peu et avec les facettes qui sont gérés
par les panels non à ces slips
premièrement il ya eu il ya les monkey
et trip place vans aussi on va sur strip
la semaine
ça permet de dire s'il faut les mettre à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur quand les
étiquettes comme c'est le cas sont du
même côté je reviens sur le graphique
donc si je rajoute un strip fasse mon
égard outside nos mamans bordurie se
délient vous partir sur la gauche
maintenant parce qu'on va faire ses
tripes texte un qui va me permettre de
modifier mon texte
donc là soit un programme dit on est sur
l'axé y donc si je fais ce trip texte y
là je dois pieds et les mains texte déjà
je vais cl
c'est en grains donc si je fais ce légal
bolt on va voir si je lis bien modifier
cet élément là ils sont passés en grains
maintenant je vais changer l'ont donc je
veux qu'il soit horizontaux je vais
passer anglais galles 0 ou alors est-ce
que c'est un ongle 90 à faire non ça
marche pas qu'est ce que j'ai oublié
anges
on peut pas détourner j'essaie deux noms
je peux pas les tournées je peux les
déplacer chez ge fait vie just et
gallaher que je peux les déplacer vers
le ou non une vie just alors est-ce que
ça voyons voir triplées inside out
ok trip texte cette espèce crippen axis
non non normalement j'aurais dit que
normalement c'est ici on aurait gelé sur
l'alignement verticale ou alors là avec
acheteuse singer plus monté il ya juste
en fait cette question de l'angle je
comprends pas on peut citer jongler mais
vous voyez c'est que c'est vraiment pas
facile d'arriver à à déplacer en fait
ces éléments là donc on peut citer
anglais
1 le tep thème les djeunes position top
ne change rien le legend position si je
l'indiquais ceux ci
dix points la question de la légende
c'est ce bloc là ça ne ne change pas la
question des des éléments je vous
montrerai tout à l'heure qu'il ya une
autre astuce peut-être pour faire que
vous voulez faire qui consiste à faire
deux graphiques ont semblé qu'on va
ensuite fusionner des retenues en tout
cas que jongler sur la position des
facettes ça peut se faire mais c'est pas
tout à fait si simple que ça en tout cas
là on les a remis du côté gauche ça peut
permettre de faciliter la lecture mais
voyez les maîtres juste au dessus c'est
pas la logique de base des facettes
alors ça serait plutôt le fait quand on
va jongler de deux éléments ensemble
je vais en profiter et dont je suis là
pour améliorer un petit peu mon
graphique 1 en changeant la position du
titre si vous souvenez on avait plate
title position
qui permet d'être si jamais pelote au
lieu de panels un peu le positionner de
manière plus globale et donc du coup on
va venir carrément jusqu ici où je peux
décider aussi de centre est complètement
mon titre en faisant flotte point title
éléments ce texte donc la scène laisse
justement horizontale donc h jost points
5 pour indiquer centre et donc zéro pour
indiquer aligné à gauche un pur indiqué
aligné à droite et points 5 pour être
centré alors qu'on est sur les petites
améliorations du graphique
là ce qui m'intéresserait se réclament
de pouvoir indiquer oui là c'est ce
qu'on appelle en anglais les tic ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des encoches la
gemmi encoches sur mon découpage
principal mais j'aimerais bien avoir des
tic's soumet découpage secondaire alors
pour ça il ya une petite astuce
d'ailleurs j'ai découvert qu'il ya pas
si longtemps que ça il faut avoir au
cours un package qui s'appelle ghk
tricks à qui donne en fait quelques
petits éléments d'amélioration sur les
graphiques et quand on a ça quand on a
du coup notre notre scale contourner
dans un fonction scan x ou un ce qu'elle
y on peut appeler on peut rajouter
l'option guide est lui passé la fonction
guide axis
minor qui est fourni en fait du coup par
ghg ghk tricks et vous allez voir ça
permet de rajouter des encoches au
niveau des des encoches au niveau du
découpage mineurs alors le découpage
mignonne en vertical on voit pas parce
qu'il n'a pas été dessinés et puis on
voit pour le moment c'est que j'ai une
encoche une ont tous roulé ici et
j'aurais plutôt envie avoir besoin
d'avoir deux au milieu en fait parce
qu'on est dans des coupes en 3 est donc
ce qu'on va pouvoir rajouter
ici c'est indiquer comment est ce qu'on
va faire des mineurs brakes et là je
vais indiqué wang
donc je vais indiquer des mineurs boixe
un tous les mois et je vais pouvoir 10 a
affiché sous forme d'un coach ces
mineurs brakes grâce à guy d'axis minor
et aux loyers ils apparaissent juste ici
c'est vraiment du détail sur
l'amélioration des graphismes et sur
certains types de graphiques
ça peut vraiment améliorer grandement la
lecture
un graphique est relativement avancé et
puis on va faire un petit cadeau bonux
qui est qui serait du coup de d'ajouter
un sur graphique une étiquette kindy le
nombre total de bons dessinée distribué
par mois mais je veux pas le détail
comme on avait pu voir la semaine
dernière entre l'école primaire et
collège voudrais juste un total de
l'ensemble
et ça ça y est pas sur le chapitre
analyseur donc ça sera un petit bonus
alors l'idée c'est que on va refaire
déjà des étiquettes un peu classique
donc je vous rappelle je vais rajouter
un gm texte pour que sa faune
vous ouvrir 10 le statut égal kranz et
si je fais ça il va me dire mais qu'est
ce qu'on va avoir comme paramètre pour
les étiquettes donc il vous rajoutez un
label égal ce qu'on va avoir et nous ce
qu'on veut avoir c'est la statistique
quand la variable quand calculé par
stade quand et pour accéder à une
variable calculée par une statistique il
faut passer par after stats c'est à dire
une variable disponible après avoir
appliqué statistiques tout simplement
et elle s'appelle quand donc ça on avait
déjà vu jour au mot ce que ça fait donc
là ce
les calculs mais il nous manquerait le
paramètre position à pour avoir la bon
positionnement est vrai je rajoute
position égale position fils point 0,5
pour arriver à des centres et ainsi je
ne précise pas par dont la position sud
mais position d'acs
parce que par défaut nos bars sont les
unes au dessus des autres
un par défaut ce que fait j'ai en tête
c'est qu'il va positionner nos
étiquettes entame de bach je vais te
rajouter un size égal 2 pour réduire la
taille des étiquettes alors par défaut à
nos étiquettes sont positionnés à laval
et le position ce pack permet de
calculer comment elles se mettent les
unes au dessus des autres lots 0,5 pour
dire à mes jeux si on mettait pas le 05
par défaut ça serait un
elles seraient positionnés en haut un
des blocs et le position stack points
0/5 c'est pour les mettre au milieu des
blocs jusqu'au là ça va à peu près bien
moi ce qui m'intéresse rsa serait de
rajouter nous pas une étiquette dans
chacun des blocs une étiquette sur le
total
et c'est là qu'on va voir les astuces
c'est qu'on peut modifier
l'association aed et esthétique n'ont
pas globalement pour graphique mais
uniquement pour une géométrie pour une
couche d'eau dès le 1 er du début là ce
sont des déclarations qui vont marcher
pour tous le graphique et si on veut
personnaliser les associations de
variables avec les sceptiques
spécifiquement pour une géométrie donné
il faut le faire à l'intérieur de
l'appel de la géométrie
alors je m sur 2 ligne pour qu on y voit
un peu plus clair
et on a un paramètre qui est ma ping
dans tout les géométries qui permet de
pouvoir lui appliquer un résultat d'un e
s pour appliquer des jaunes tri
spécifiquement pour cette géométrie
n'est pas une autre par exemple la belle
qui n'est pas utilisée par jérôme bats
j'aurais très bien pu le définir ici
dans gm texte il manque une virgule et
on aurait eu la même chose ce que je
pourrais faire c'est dire
mais pour mon calcul de jaune texte je
ne veux pas prendre en compte le
distinguo partie vit tablissements donc
annulé l'association je veux que qui
rien en fait pour le paramètre fils et
si je fais ce fils égale nul je
désactive
en fait je désire aussi l'avarié un
petit baiser à this man tilt mais que
pour manger en texte comme elle n'y est
plus
maintenant je n'ai qu'une seule valeur
qui calculait barbares puisqu'on sait
plus distinguer entre collèges lycées
donc j'ai bien le nom total de bandes
dessinées distribués sur un mois donné
ce que je veux
refaire fait la position je veux pas du
coup le m ça ne sert plus à rien de
prendre position joe stack donc on va
remettre sur la position par défaut et
donc la position par défaut voyez ça me
positionne mon étiquette je sais pas si
vous les voyez bien à la valeur calculée
donc le 1115 mis en hauteur à 1115 on y
est presque mais c'est pas tout à fait
visible et là on va utiliser quelques
astuces supplémentaires dont gm texte
d'une part on a un code vous avez déjà
avant ne vous avez un vide just et 1h 13
avaient déjà c'était pour dire
l'alignement verticale et je vais dire
si je met un alors vous voyez ça me les
aligne par le haut donc ils sont juste
en dessous du point et si je mets 0 je
me souviens jamais le cas des deux faut
mettre un et ça ne l'a bien positionné
juste au-dessus l'étiquette là c'est
déjà un petit peu mieux mais j'aimerais
bien des cas les toutous mais point un
tout petit peu relais m un peu plus haut
et donc du coup je vais utiliser pour sa
note il y pour dire décalé - si je mets
50 d'une valeur de 50 ans auteur alors
c'est peut-être prince et si je mets 500
ça fera peut-être beaucoup mieux voyons
voir avec 500 est là avec cinq sens à
mes desquels un petit peu trop mais ça
met à monter donc là je vais peut-être
mettre juste cent
marche pas forcément très bien c'est
qu'on voit aussi un autre petit souci
c'est que là j'ai dû mettre un size un
tout petit parce que
j'ai beaucoup de bars et donc si jamais
je mets des points partout si j'augmente
elle a taillé pour avoir quelque chose
de plus lisible en trois peut-être que
ça va commencer à ce marché les uns sur
les autres c'est un petit peu un des
soucis qu'on rend compte alors déjà j'ai
fait ce que je peux faire les revenir à
quelque chose un petit peu plus
intermédiaire est ce que j'aimerais du
coup c'est pas mettre ça pour tous les
mois mais que un mois sur 2 1
parce que en mettant un mois sur deux je
vais moins surchargées mon graphique etc
comment dire que je voudrais que moi sur
deux et comprendre qu'un mois ci
pour pour la géométrie jeunes texte
premier élément c'est que un mois sur
deux je peux pas déjà je pourrais dire
je ne veux garder que les observations
d'accord j'ai dans mon fichier bd une
variable mois la db cbd qui contient le
mois sous une forme numérique
je pourrais dire que je veux garder
uniquement les mois impairs
alors pour rappel pour son temps
chantage c'est ce qu'on appelle le
module hausse et le reste de la division
entière si japhet modulo 2 l'obtient
soit 0 contre le chiffre est père soit 1
quand le chiffre est un père donc moi ce
que je voudrais c'est uniquement les
mois impairs donc les mois ou bd mois
modulo 2 est égal à 1
donc si j'appliquais cette condition
avec 1 filter j'aurai moins de données
et bien ce que je vais faire j'aime
texte je vais passer un jeu de données
que pour cette géométrie l'a donc comme
on a vu qu'avec mapping on peut donner d
d d d esthétique propre à uniquement
cette géométrie là avec les paramètres
data je peux indiquer un jeu de données
qui ne servira que pour cette géométrie
là qui viendra remplacer le bd qu'on a
passé globalement et dont il si je veux
dire bd center avec ma condition
c'est à dire que je dis que pour gm
texte pourrait dessiner jeunes texte tu
vas pas prendre ça on va prendre bd avec
ce style traditionnel ce qui fait que je
ne transmet que les données des mois
impairs et dont vous voyez j'obtiens
bien ce que je voulais c'est à dire ne
dessine et le nombre observé uniquement
pour ses mots un père je veux augmenter
un tout petit peu pour que ça soit un
peu plus lisible et je me rencontrent
ici j'ai un petit problème de lecture
c'est que le 6028 là est légèrement
coupé parce que le montrent pas tout à
fait un c'est donc ce que je peux faire
c'est augmenter en fait un tout petit
peu mon graphique est donc dans mon ski
y tu n'en es pas moi je rajouter un ski
et à continuer puisque la chine variable
continu
je vais pouvoir modifier les paramètres
limites et dire que manuellement je vais
aller de 0 à 6 jeux mais si mes cinq
sens je j'augmente les chaînes ont un
peu plus espaces et on voit mieux
par contre la cdu que ça devient du coup
peut-être un peu trop collé donc je vais
changer mon âge y passer à 200 il ya un
mois de ça quelque chose d'un peu plus
décoller donc tout ça ce sont des
petites astuces pour arriver à faire
évoluer un graphique un petit peu
différemment et rajouter des des choses
et je vous propose du coup que on
continue de récupération faisant cette
fois ci un deuxième graphique puisque
nous avons un indicateur intéressant
c'est je vous rappelle ans ne regarder
que le nombre de bandes dessinées
distribue chaque mois mais si vous vous
souvenez de ce qu'on a dans nos données
je voulais remontre on a dans chaque
rapport d'activités le nombre de bandes
dessinées distribués et le nom d'élèves
rencontrés autrement dit on se doute
bien que mal à on a distribué trois
bandes dessinées pour trois élèves on a
remis une à chacun mais là on a
distribué 12 bande dessinée pour 6
élèves c'est à dire qu'on ait dû
remettre deux bandes dessinées à chacun
des élèves
ici on a eu trois bandes dessinées pour
deux élèves donc un indicateur et on
pourrait intéressé de savoir ce qu'il a
changé au cours du temps c'est le nombre
de bons dessine de bandes dessinées
distribué par élève rencontre et donc le
nombre moyen de bd par élève pour voir
si on en a donné 6 à cet indicateur la
d'activité a changé au cours du temps
donc qui va nous intéresser
c'est donc évolution
le ratio bd art élèves repartant du
début donc je vais faire un géologue bd
ce que je veux du courroux présenter
pour un par un x ça va être la date et
en y
je veux du coup là ce ratio bd distribué
par élève en contre vous voyez là je
peux tout à fait faire un calcul à la
volée avait pas besoin d'avoir créé une
variable en amont il à la volée je vais
faire mon calcul billets distribués par
les rencontrer et on va faire j'aime
punt
alors ce qu'on voit c'est
chacune des dates on a pas mal de points
différents forcément à ce qui se passe
c'est que là le calcul a été fait ligne
par ligne dans mon fichier d'origine
bande dessinée or moi ce qui m'intéresse
ce n'est pas cette valeur là pour chacun
des rapports d'activité c'est en moyenne
pour pour le mois de janvier
alors ce qu'on peut retenir c'est que ce
qu'il nous faut calculer en fait c'est
la moyenne pondérée de la grandeur bd
distribué / élèves rencontrés il faut
pondérer cet indicateur la part élèves
rencontrés pour refaire la moyenne
globalement or la librairie gg galli
nous avons déjà abordé à plusieurs
reprises qui propose notamment cette
statistique propre un stade propre qui
permet de mettre des étiquettes de
pourcentage propose aussi une
statistique qui s'appelle will it is
mine
donc si je fais stats je vais charger
parlons gg galli jamais de mémoire et
maintenant je vais appeler dans mon gm
paint statistiques waiting mines
donc là ce que ça m'a fait voyez je n'ai
plus qu'un seul point par date et donc
il
la moyenne de toutes mes observations
sauf que la moyenne
il a considéré chaque observation avec
la même valeur or forcément le la ligne
où on a vu 25 élèves ont plus que les
lignes on en a vu 12
donc il faut que l'on pense à pondérer
par élèves rencontrés et la j'obtiens
bien un bon indicateur qui est qui est
elle qui est du coup j'ai bien un point
d'observation par mois alors on va tout
de suite peut-être se rajouter un thème
clean pour avoir quelque chose d'un peu
plus clair et puis je vais tout de suite
reprendront tous demoustier xy là pour
avoir quelque chose aussi deux plus
lisible sur les mois vous voyez là géré
fait graphique
nous avons bien un point d'observation
par mois supposons que comme tout à
l'heure on avait fait le distinguo entre
les collèges et les écoles
j'aimerais bien calme avoir bondi d'un
contre collège aimé écoles donc je vais
rajouter je vais représenter ça comme
tout à l'heure pas redécoller donc je
vais appeler color égale type
établissements
et là ce que va faire stade white is
mine
il va bien comprendre qu'il faut
calculer un point différent pour chacune
donc pour chaque date en fait les deux
points parce qu'il aura fait le calcul
séparément pour chacune des couleurs
grâce à sam des grands intérêts alors on
va également pour être cohérent utiliser
le même code couleur que tout à l'heure
donc celui du bois sauf que là c'est pas
le parent à modifier ces paramètres
color donc j'ai rappelé qu'elle colore
bright
ça me permet de garder comparatif et
puis
ce qu'on va faire c'est au lieu de
représenter des points on peut mettre
des petits segments entre eux des points
pour avoir quelque chose d'un peu plus
joli
alors ça ça existe un sauf que je me
souviens jamais ou est ce que c'est
exactement mais vous l'avez quand vous
entendez sur un analyseur donc c'est je
vais sur analyseur approfondie et angelo
2 est donc là on va regarder sur les
nouvelles géométrie et notamment voilà
point relier donc j'aurais pu faire des
lignes où je peux utiliser gg jumping
passe à qui fournit aussi par régis h
catherine
alors pour vous montrer ce que ça donne
j'aurais pu dire moi ce que je veux
c'est de faire les lignes donc j'aurais
fait jérôme line d'accord et je retenu
ce graphique je les mets tout de suite
aussi la légende en bas
donc là
tiens le même graphique mais avec avec
des lignes vont on aurait pu aussi avoir
recours du coup au lieu de jeuxonline ag
aum boys passe une petite combinaison
des deux qui en fait vous présente les
points observés avec des tirs est entre
les deux donc c'est en fait une ligne
avec des points l'avantagé c'est que du
coup on voit bien où étaient nos points
d'observation donc là ce n'est même pas
une passe il est fourni par gégé h 4 x
une autre possibilité c'est de dire je
regardais ligne avec un jeu online mais
je vais rajouter les points par dessus
donc gm paint tâte un gaz waited 1
bien les points et les points sont
reliés entre eux il ya plus aux petits
traits blancs mais ça la lisibilité ici
restent bonnes ce qui est important à un
moment donné c'est qu'on arrive qui va
être important c'est que on comprenne
graphique l'intérêt éventuellement de
mettre les points en plus de la ligne
c'est que ça permet de comprendre que on
a des observations à des points précis
est en fait une saisine que pour nous
afficher la tendance et la courbe
général pour en est chose un poil plus
lisible on pourrait dire aussi qu'on
veut avoir des nids un peu plus épaisse
donc j'aurais pu faire par exemple
manuellement dire ça y est égal à un
fabregas a épaissi on a quelque chose
d'un peu plus épais et éventuellement on
peut on peut on peut changer sur l'un et
l'autre ce qui m'intéresse maintenant
ici et ça va être une des astuces
complémentaires et là on va tomber sur
des choses un petit peu plus compliqué
parce que beaucoup
seront pas faire ça simplement s'est
rajouté les intervalles de confiance de
la mesure observé avant d'aller sur
l'intervalle de confiance juste une
petite précision
excusez moi je me rends compte que je
voulais pas montrer quelque chose c'est
que là notre graphique g15 2.0 2.5 mais
je vais pas à la racine la l0 ce qui est
pas forcément très bon et donc ce que
j'aimerais c'est pouvoir diriger pelote
rajoute mois 0 son graphique
s'il n'y est pas et ça ça va pouvoir se
faire assez facilement avec juste
expérience limite je vais dire y égal
zéro et ça lui c'est un syndic inclus 0
dans l'axé des x donc 6 0 et pas dedans
automatiquement il va élargir le minimum
le maximum pour être sûr que 0 et bien
inclus dans la limite c'est différent du
paramètres limitent sa danse kyle xy ou
là on doit indiquer la valeur minimum la
valeur maximum la avec expand limite on
dit juste je veux inclure cette valeur
zéro dans mon graphique et donc du coup
l'aja grâce et connaît bien le zéro qui
représentait ce qui peut aussi nous
intéresser ça ferait de souligner une
certaine valeur par exemple j'aimerais
bien dessinés manière un peu plus
précise la valeur une console c'est une
valeur un peu seuil et donc pour ça je
vais faire une ligne horizontale
je peux appeler geum h line et on me
demande y intercepte donc ça quel
endroit elles coupent l'accès des
immigrés pts à 1 et en faisons ceci l'a
géré dessiner une ligne horizontale ce
qui permet de bien marquer un
ce niveau 1.77 valeur 1 qu' une valeur
un peu seul
je vais tout de suite aussi nettoyer un
petit peu on fera plus tard et là on va
aborder coup la question de rajouter des
intervalles de confiance autour de mes
deux courbes
alors ce qui est un petit peu ce qui est
un petit peu compliqué c'est de savoir
mais comment qu'elle serait l'intervalle
de confiance qui est pertinent là ce que
j'ai c'est un ratio et j'ai un nombre
entier / un nombre entier j'ai donc j'ai
donc un ratio de deux nombres entiers et
on peut calculer un intervalle de
confiance pour un ratio de te nombre
entier avec un test de poisson pour
rappel la loi de poisson elle concerne
en fait là un nombre de d'événements un
nombre d'occurrences donc l équipe pour
prédire des nombres et donc entier mais
on peut appliquer ça un ratio c'est à
dire un nombre d'événements par rapport
à une curée d'observation et donc il est
possible de faire un test de poisson
avec a du coup à 9,7 et donc supposons
par exemple j'ai 48 bande dessinée
distribuer à 27 élèves
je peux à utiliser la fonction poisson
test pour calculer 48 bd divisé
distribué à 27 élèves ce que j'obtiens
un danger un test de poisson alors en
fait c'est le bruit dit en baisse parce
qu'on considère le dénominateur comme un
temps d'exposition à nombre de personnes
années mais ça peut être c'est pas
forcément quelque chose d'intemporel ce
qu'on voit c'est que j'obtiens du coup à
une valeur de 1 77 ans est bien 48 / 27
donne 1 67 et je mets cet intervalle de
confiance entre 1,31 et 2,35
la question c'est comme moi est ce que
je peux faire pour récupérer parce que
là on va essayer maintenant faire le
calcul manière programmatique cette
information donc des gens va stocker
pour comprendre quel est le format de
l'objet renvoyé par la fonction poids
sont sg stocky le résultat dans un objet
de l'appel test il va regarder ça c'est
bon tu testes d'accord c'est une liste
de neuf objets c'est juste content je te
tais style melun primes de manière à peu
jolie à l'écran mais un objet donc c'est
une liste de neuf objets mon intervalle
de confiance est contenue dans un bruit
qui s'appelle complainte qui est un
vecteur de deux valeurs donc si je veux
récupérer cette information là je peux
le faire de deux manières différentes
soit avec dollars puisque le dollar me
permet d'accéder un élément nommé d'une
liste je renvoie aux tous premiers ou
deuxièmes webinaire test dollar contre 1
une autre manière de récupérer ça une
autre fois un peu différemment ce avec
la fonction plug du package piot qui ces
parties de tailles diverses
ah ça serait test bloc
ouf 1
donc on lui pas en soi ces blocs test
confins de soi c'est de tester on lui
passe avec le piper bloc et ont indiqué
les mots qu'on veut extrait en fait plug
va se débrouiller tout seul boire s'il
faut utiliser un dièse décrocha en
fatigue
il généralise un petit peu l'élément qui
se passe et que là ce qu'on obtient
c'est une lecteur avec deux valeurs si
moi ce que je veux c'est récupérer
l'intervalle de confiance bas c'est à
dire la première des deux valeurs
soit je passe par la syntaxe avec mon
monde yeahs et ensuite je rajoute des
crochets pour indiquer que je veux
récupérer le premier élément dont il
utilise un dollar pour récupérer
'confiant' puis un crochet pour
récupérer le premier élément
ou alors je peux utiliser bloc et
j'indique la deuxième niveau de
sélection c'est d'abord confins puis
premier objet et j'obtiens en fait la
même chose
donc là on a vu comment quand je clique
un test de poisson je peux récupérer
l'intervalle de confiance bas et si je
vais récupérer l'intervalle de confiance
aux le v12 utiliser plaque 'confiant' 2
sauf que c'est
encore suffisant là j'ai vu comment
faire pour calculer à un test de poisson
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si j'ai
plusieurs tests de poisson a calculé un
supposons j'ai un vecteur ou un tableau
de données ou jean numérateur dont 50 25
32 48
j'ai un dénominateur encore 25 17 25 31
pardon est ce que je peux faire poisson
test de mon numérateur et le
dénominateur pour faire le calcul pour
25 se raconte sur 25 25 sur 17 32 sur 25
et 48 sur 31 malheureusement ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que la fonction
poisson test elle n'est pas faite pour
gérer ou plusieurs thèses de poissons
les uns à la suite des autres et donc du
coup ce que l'on va avoir besoin c'est
une fonction qui va nous permettre
d'appliquer poisson test à chaque étape
et pour ça on peut avoir recours
toujours avec pio on a des fonctions qui
sont maps ou les fonctions map de sa
fonction map
je prends un vecteur et je vais
appliquer une fonction sur chaque
élément du vecteur la fonction n'a de je
prends deux vecteurs et je vais pouvoir
appliquer une fonction alternativement
sur le premier sur le 2e alors comment
ça s'écrit tout ça si de toute façon
nous amène toujours à bien regarder un
l'aide des fonctions pour y voir un peu
plus clair
elles vous sont présentés ici mais
l'idée c'est que map 2
je lui passais un premier vecteur donc à
7 le numérateur la liste de valeurs du
numérateur puis main liste au
dénominateur
et puis indique une fonction appliquée
alors je pourrais faire par exemple
poisson test
je fais ça je récupère une liste qui
contient des résultats de mes quatre
tests de poisson c'est à dire on a
appliqué poisson test au premier au
deuxième et au troisième j'ai une liste
de résultats de poisson avec chacun des
ré avec moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
récupérés à ce stade que que
l'intervalle pas l'intervalle de
confiance bas donc ce que je vais faire
c'est que au lieu de dire juste un nom
de fonctions appliquée je vais passer ma
propre fonction est ce que permet maps
et map 2 c'est d'impliquer une fonction
a créé à la baule est né dans ce cas là
il faut juste commencé par un tilt de
fertiles et je dire voilà qu'est ce que
je veux faire je veux appliquer poisson
test alors point hic c'est pour dire
l'élément du premier vecteur point y
l'élément du deuxième vecteur donc point
avec ses poings y sont des raccourcis
qui permet de dire où je passe en fait
les éléments des deux vecteurs du médium
que je vais appliquer son que
j'appliquais map 2e étape par étape
ça va être génial il est là dessus et
dont je vais appliquer plop plop pardon
confins ce donc là pour
quel est mon dos nu mais chaque élément
de dénomme on va les faire un par un
pour la première ligne vu appliquer
poisson texte première valeur de 9 2
nuls première valeur se dénomme puis
j'applique blog qu'on fait un si
j'exécute ça alors forcément c'est pas
de texte mais poisson test je récupère
une liste mais le premier est mon
analyse c'est que les intervalles de
confiance bas on y est presque
ce que j'aimerais par contre c'est pas
récupéré une liste toutes les ag des
objets qui sont simples j'aimerais
récupérer un infecteur de nombres en
l'occurrence là ce sont des nombres
numérique ce sont des noms qui dénombre
10 d'abord et donc je vais utiliser non
pas map 2 mai map de underscore dbl qui
dit je veux récupérer un résultat sous
forme d'un lecteur numérique et
j'obtiens du coup maintenant ma liste
d'intervalle de confiance pas maintenant
qu'on a ça on va du coc pouvoir calculer
à la volée dans un intervalle de
confiance un peu plus haut donc
revenons-en dans notre graphique on va
faire en fait c'est qu'on va rajouter un
bris bonne j'ai un jeu wii bonne des
fruits précise stats white is mine donc
se ruent bon ça va être quelque chose
qu'on va pouvoir afficher et ici je vous
montre le géant home ou lisbonne ce
qu'il a besoin c'est qu'on indique ans
chaque endroit la valeur minimum et la
valeur minimum de y donc on définisse un
y mines et un y mc donc ici je vais
indiqué
que y mines ça va être les bains en fait
on va utiliser ceci ces maps tout dbl
num dénomme poissons tels xy toc
sauf que moi ce que je veux c'est pas
nue mais dénomme les deux vecteurs que
j'ai créé là mais c'est comment accéder
au numérateur au dénominateur de ma
variable d'aidé distribuée sur les neuf
rencontres
si je reviens à l'aide stats vous voyez
une mine
on voit que ce que fait style it is mine
elle va calculer à savon de variables
qui seront du coup accessible avec after
stats et notamment elle va avoir
numérateur et dénominateur accessible
je rappelle le dénominateur ça va être
la somme des poids donc c'est la somme
due élèves rencontrés donc c'est bien ce
que l'on veut donc là qu'il faut que je
dis c'est que ce que je vois passer ses
afters stats de dhelemme de numérateur
donc un premier élément je vais pas
cesser la variable numérateur disponible
après qu'on ait appliqué à statistiques
donc c'est double after stats et ici
j'ai appliqué after stats dénominateur
main
en moins y max c'est la même chose la
seule chose qui varient là dedans c'est
qu'on prend le deuxième élément est donc
la voyez je calcule à la volée les
intervalles de confiance aux ébats mais
au lieu d'avoir fait tout en amont ça se
fait la bonne et on va voir l' avantage
que ça va avoir juste derrière alors
qu'est ce qu'il me dit il lui manque un
y mineurs y max ben oui j'ai fait y
mines y mine j'ai pas fait de y max
pardon alors j'ai maintenant mais ruban
qui sont dessinés on va avoir besoin des
deux petites choses déjà sur mur coupe
bon on va faire une petite variation
c'est que des gens va colorisées le
ruban et donc il lui manque un par ahmed
fils donc dans mon ruban on va lui
appliquer des esthétiques perso et je
vais faire un e s par ma ping
alès des jeux d'hier fils et l'âne on
corrige par type établissements donc je
vais colorisé par le type
d'établissement
là on récupère les couleurs pour que ça
soit facile il faut que je dise qu'on me
dise hammam et chaînes de couleur donc
je vais appliquer scraire celle prize
comme ça on utilise la même et elle de
couleurs mais l'astuce c'est que mary
ben je veux les rendre transparents pour
pas que ça dessine tout csii trastour
donc manger au moins bonne il faut que
je rajoute en dessous donc là c'est pas
dans le s1 parce que c'est pas quelque
chose qui vraiment une variable indiqué
point 25.5 pour ans mon ruban
transparent c'était encore un peu coloré
et peut-être que je vais encore allégé
avec 1.25 voyez là j'ai des rubans qui
sont plus transparents à l'aise on
arrive à voir les du coup on peut voir
quand est ce que les courbes se
superposent
par contre le ruban des signes d très au
dessus et en dessous ça c'est parce
qu'il hérite du paramètre color qu'on a
passé tout en haut
donc ce que je vais faire je vais
désactiver color dans le mapping que du
ruban qui c'est qui va pur dessinée et
voyez là j'ai des rubans qui sont plus
faciles à voir et je vais peut-être
encore les rendre encore un peu plus
transparent jeu des sma points 15 on
veut vraiment que le ru bon swing
informations additionnelles ont plu mais
là j'ai du coup rajouter mais intervalle
de confiance sur mon graphique alors
c'est pris en compte ici dans ma légende
mais j'aimerais éventuellement que cette
partie du rebond soient pas comptées
dans le dans la légende que les gens ne
se concentre uniquement sur la partie
très donc je pourrais dire que la
géométrie rue bon ribbon ne devrait pas
compter dans la légende
alors si je ré ouvre ses parties
m commun à toutes les géométries il ya
un option cho lee jones et donc si dans
mon ribbon je rajoute l'option chaud les
djeunes égal face ça voudrait dire que
cette couche là cette géométrie l'année
pas à prendre en compte dans ma légende
1 et voyez elle n'apparaît plus ici dans
la légende
on va nettoyer encore un tout petit peu
notre graphique donc je vais supprimer
quelques étiquettes et fils donc là je
vais y nettoyer fils et color pour être
sûr que les deux soient bien
correctement parce qu'ils sont combinés
dont l'âge est bien vide et les deux et
puis on va remettre quand même un titre
bd nombre moyen de bd remise
un élève
je m'appelle plus à la fin voilà alors
tout le coup
fait ici un pour le calcul des
intervalles de confiance et puis le fait
que bd distribués sur il avait rencontré
on aurait pu et c'est une autre manière
de faire dire bah en avant je prends le
fichier bd je vais faire un somme rise
par type établissements et puis du coup
je vais additionner b distribué je vais
additionner élèves rencontrés dans le
sommer et j'obtiens un bd par mois par
établissement parce que j'ai avec un
groupe by mois établissements d'accord
et ensuite je calcule pas moins y je
peux faire le coup de calcul distribué
sur les rencontres et je peux calculer
mais intervalle de confiance à cette
étape là et donc du coup seulement après
j'ai précalculée mes différentes
statistiques avant d'affaires à peine
âgée belote qui est une approche qu'on
trouve très régulièrement et vous verrez
souvent qu'on vous chercher sur internet
des idéaux des solutions c'est éléments
là qui va apparaître
sauf que
ça a un petit souci c'est que si je fais
ça et que maintenant je veux refaire le
même graphique en séparant d'un côté les
de fer et un facettes sur le pays
et bien c'est à dire que tout ce que
j'aurais dû faire avant je dois leur
calcul est comme la toux les calculs se
font à la volée je veux maintenant
séparés par pays c'est à dire je veux
rajouter à gauche donc l'affairé de
cause va au pays un distingué la
bordurie et la syldavie et ben voila
j'ai juste à rajouter deux facettes tout
le graphique ce se refait de manière
automatique puisque tout est calculé
je supprime à un moment donné la
séparation de couleur terre calcul est
donc en fait le gros avantage qu'on a
ici à à faire des choses à la volée
c'est de permettre justement ces
éléments alors petite astuce j'aimerais
quand même bien répéter mes axes pour du
coup utilisez plutôt le fasse un très
bon greed qu'on a vu avec 1,8 pictures
pour améliorer un tout petit peu la
lecture et là on a eu
dernière petite astuce qui n'est pas non
plus sur le site analyseur donc du coup
j'en profite c'est j'aimerais bien
pouvoir rajouter les valeurs à la toute
fin
donc rajouter sur le côté d'accord
[Musique]
les les valeurs observées pour la
bordurie pour la syldavie donc quelles
sont ces valeurs atteintes donc là pour
le coup je vais aller chercher
j'ai déjà dit leur ai donc je refais
ringer en texte les petite particularité
c'est que du coup je ne veux que le tout
dernier pays d'accord je vais avoir être
donc je vais prendre date à cbd
je vais garder que le dernier mois donc
s'il tarde ces dates égale max de date
il faut que j'applique ma statistique
qui est widing mine pour le calcul si
genre
à la statistique whiting mines la valeur
calculée est accessible avec after stats
s'appelle y le waikiki gac d'accord donc
ce que je vais voir présenter je vais
indiquer un mapping juste pour pour ce
graphique là je vais rajouter dans ma
ping que la belle égale after stats de y
voyons voir ce qu'on obtient alors il ya
déjà une première erreur dans mon fils
tard effectivement cette date égalé
galmac date une condition être ensuite
la fonction l'after parce que c'est pas
after mais after stati prennent toujours
lire les messages d'erreurs ça nous
indique à sa vente de choses donc
plusieurs choses on a récupéré ici
déjà la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a
récupéré les valeurs elles sont
affichées par contre voyez elles sont
parfois l'une sur l'autre on peut on
jouer revenir après dessus mais on va
déjà ignoré deux trois petites choses là
elles sont affichées d'accord avec tous
les chiffres de décimales donc
j'aimerais uniquement à voir que une
décimale vous pour rappel on peut
utiliser la fonction de number du
package wsop pour remettre en forme un
petit peu différemment
je vais appeler games et à manger un
texte ici mon label arrête ici donc je
vais chercher number donc géré
transforme la valeur est dans mon number
the number acteurs staff et je vais
indiquer à cul mais ici égale points
cadets
je n'ai plus que 1 chiffres après la
virgule et après on va détruire la
légende dont je vais retirer cholet
jones égal face pour mon jeune texte ce
qui fait que le à va disparaître de la
légende
maintenant ce que je veux c'est que vous
point ça situé à droite de lahoud est
positionné donc c'est à dire qu'en fait
qu'ils soient alignés à la gauche veut
sa poésie de la position donc on va
rajouter dans le gène text 1h just égal
0 et puis j'aimerais le décaler un tout
petit peu sur la droite pense que c'est
plus facile
donc je vais rajouter un hud 6 et là on
va dire l'équivalent de cinq jours dont
je les met 5
quand on est sur un axe de date d'accord
on a dit que les grandeurs vous en avons
besoin de nombre de jours donc là ça
décale de cinq jours dans le dessin si
je mettais disent ça desquels un petit
peu plus par contre je me rends compte
que en faisant ça je n'arrive pas à
pouvoir parce que mon axe dx du coup et
pas assez grand donc ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que je gex j'élargisse ponderach
dx et j'aimerais bien rajouter un mois
alors si je fais max de bd date
j'obtiens du coup la valeur maximum et
c'est un objet de type
j'aimerais faire un calcul sur un mois
dans ce que j'aimerais c'est pouvoir
ajouter un mois et l'oubli des deux
permet de faire du calcul sur des dates
notamment parce que je pourrais rajouter
membres alors en ce 1
vous avez donc
manche avec un ace qui permet de créer
un objet qui va durer un mois
10h01 ça vous permet de créer un objet
qui dure un an
si je faisais hier un plus bas à 3 ce
que je retiendrai c'est un objet qu'ils
c'est une période qui dure un an trois
mois en fait un lubrique et propose un
objet qui s'appelle des périodes il
permet de représenter une période de
temps en amenez-moi jour heure minute
seconde parce que quand tu es des
secondes ça va un tout les toutes les
minutes font 60 secondes quand on est
sur des choses c'est un peu plus
compliqué les jours font par certains
jours de l'année ont une seconde ou pas
en plus bon ça c'est pas encore prêt
mais il ya des mois de 10 jours des mois
des voix de 28 jours des mois de 31
jours d année de 365 ou 360 là donc
c'est vrai que calculés sur des dates ça
devient compliqué parce que les années
les moines sont pas constants donc là on
a une manière de représenter ces
informations-là et d'intérêts c'est
qu'on peut combiner une période avec une
date si je fais max des dates plus
minces
1 j'obtiens pour monter un mac bd date
c'était le 1er juillet 51
+91 j'obtiens le 1er août 1951 j'ai
rajouté un mois malade et donc et pas ce
que je vais essayer de faire c'est de
faire un exposé limits expanding
ajoutez à la kz2 hic c'est de valeur là
et du coup ma
à cette place pour pouvoir mais petit
texte pour avoir mes étiquette qui se
dessine l'avantagé c'est que ici j'ai
pas mis une valeur manuel donc si jamais
j'avais j'étais sur une enquête qui est
en cours et où je donnais évolué au
cours de ce mois 10 ionel se refait au
fur et à mesure alors je suis en train
de m'en rends compte que j'ai dû faire
deux experts il est où mon exposé limite
je vais les ges
il est là et si vous regardez j'avais
déjà un autre expert ni limite un peu
plus haut dont je vais tous vous
remettre dans un seul externe limite
donc la ligne 89
je vais supprimer ce ex pas de limite et
je vais mettre à jour celui de 81 pour
en mettre qu'un seul petit dernier petit
détail
eh bien j'ai envie des fichiers le texte
plutôt en gr 1
donc pour ici je l'indiqué fils égale
bowles et c'est pas ça parce que ces
fonds ne s'est pas fait et quand on a un
doute on retourne voir la documentation
hélas le petit soucis que j'ai c'est
qu'à un moment donné et bien envoyé le
2.3 et 2.0 sont clairement visibles sur
la droite mais pour la bordurie les deux
chiffres se superpose à l'autre il
s'écrie blanc dessus dessous
est ce que j'aimerais c'est que mes
étiquettes ne se superposent pas et ça
c'est possible parce que souvent d'après
mme quand vous faites des graphiques de
résultats de on l'avait vu avec les
traînées factorielle c'est qu'on a le
package gg repele propose justement une
géométrie qui permet de repousser les
poules alors ce soit simple sg hommes
repele gm
ce repère d'accord donc c'est la même
chose j'ai un texte sauf qu'on demande à
ce que les étiquettes ne soit pas l'un
au dessus de l'autre je vous remonte
notre graphique qui est là d'accord
donc je vais remplacer mon jeune texte
par jérôme textes européens et voyez ça
déplacé les deux valeurs ici les deux
qui sont arrondis dire la même valeur
1,7 pour qu'il ne se superposent pas si
on regarde l'aide de jeunes texte
repères qui étaient là on a en plus
normalement un endroit qui nous permet
de dire si on autorise aux à quel point
on autorise en fait les points assez
qu'ils s'écartent et les uns des autres
et mais on peut aussi dire si on
autorise les écarts uniquement sur
uniquement sur lac 2 x ou sur l'accès y
parce que là ce qui est un tout petit
peu embêtant quand je reviens à mon
graphique c'est que ça me les a décalé
mais ils sont maintenant sur graphique
et j'aurais voulu que sade médical
uniquement en hauteur pour les séparer
mais sans les déplacer sur la gauche ou
la droite
alors si je retourne sur l'aide jean
mouro tél
vox pas de la belle patine la bête r non
la bataille
onze poules donc ça c'est là les
attirances là c'est dire
sion directions in which to adjust
positionne la balle et on peut du coup
limité à de bouger que sur l'axé x donc
on va essayer de faire ça si je retourne
sur mon geum texte rappelle j'avais
rajouté un direction égale y ait là
voyez les étiquettes sont séparés pour
pu se superposer mais uniquement en y
[Musique]
même si ici l'an 70 n'a pas été
peut-être aussi efficace là parce qu'ils
ont l'air de s'être approché il aurait
pu être plus efficace voilà qui ferait
augmenter un petit peu la force de
répulsion entre les points bocoum je
retourne sur fichier dead horse
la force entre les points les forces
poule je rajoute force égale 2 que ça
joue pas voilà je
répulsion entre les points et voyez là
les points étaient beaucoup plus séparés
donc voilà voyez en fait on peut
vraiment améliorer le graphique au fur
et à mesure avec plein d'éléments on n'a
pas besoin de tout connaître par coeur
ce qui est important c'est de savoir
qu'est ce qui peut exister ou est-ce
qu'on peut les retrouver et comment on
va progressivement complexifier un
graphique
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que le
graphite base a été très rapide à faire
quasiment dans tous ces cas là ce qui
est finalement loup ce qui nous prend
beaucoup beaucoup de temps c'est
d'arriver à construire le graphique
finale voyez on a des graphiques ils
font quasiment 50 60 lignes de code
parce qu'on arrive sur des choses qui
sont plus en plus complexe même si le
graphique à vue d'oeil a l'air d'être
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus simple la
toute dernière chose que ce que je
voudrais vous présenter les quais 1 pour
continuer sur les graphiques puisque la
semaine prochaine on rebasculera sur sur
de l'analyse donc retenez que vous avez
sur est engagée pelote 2 dans les
chapitres d'analyseurs dans la sous
section approfondir un qui présente une
partie de ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui et
d'autres éléments encore en fait il ya
plein de choses qui sont possibles et et
tout ça en fait voilà ça peut vous y
retrouverez à cet endroit là et on
apprend au fur et à mesure parce qu'il
ya plein de choses qui sont
effectivement envisageable ce qu'on va
avoir c'est notamment comment on fait
pour combiner plusieurs graphiques
parce que ça pour le coup c'est quelque
chose qui est intéressant et vous avez
un chapitre dédié à ça alors il ya
plusieurs approches vous avez le package
complotent la fonction claude bride vous
avez patchwork qui est un autre package
avec une logique un petit peu différente
et puis
tant dans beaucoup aux ouvrages et
évoqué une époque une fonction qui
s'appelait multi plates et vous
trouverez une version un peu propres de
ce paquet multiples hoc dans package il
utilise qui m'ont package un peu fourre
tout sauf que voilà il n'est pas
toujours facile à installer
donc je vous invite à regarder plutôt
pelote quid de mettre de manière
générale et du coup ça va me permettre
d'en revenir à la demande de tout à
l'heure de savourer ce qu'on préfère de
graphiques l'un au dessus de l'autre
donc là on va essayer de combiner
plusieurs graphiques alors déjà là le
beau graphique qu'on a fait sur le
nombre moyen je vais sauvegarde est donc
une des moyens je sauvegarde en un objet
là je me mets un petit print de nb moyen
par mon pilote ce qui permet de
l'affiché à l'écran et je vais revenir
sur le graphique on avait tout à l'heure
où nous avions du coup ce géologue b d
ici là notre premier graphique de tout à
l'heure où on les fait là au dessus de
l'autre alors on va essayer de faire un
graphique que pour la bordurie non je
vais faire les coller
je vais faire un graphique bordurie donc
je pars jay plus de bd mais je vais
faire uniquement la bordurie dont filtre
pays légal égale bordurie et qu'on va
changer
simplifier graphique 1 ce stade la jirs
supprimer ce gène texte je vais pas
mettre de titre pour le moment on va pas
mettre du coup deux facettes du coup les
besoins d'esprit alors donc la voyons
voir j'ai un premier graphique bordurie
j'ai finir à quelque part à il ya une
erreur
il ya un double opus qui traîne que j'ai
fait mon graphique bordurie et on va de
l'affiché à l'écran vous voyez là on a
un graphique un peu plus un des piégeurs
faire la même chose mais pour la suite
david on reprend le même code et je vais
faire du coup syldavie
elle est donc
la vie que je vais faire on va charger
quand plantes et on va
claude grid donc la fonction claude
bride va nous permettre de combiner
plusieurs graphiques qu'on a créé
auparavant
donc si je fais pelote grid de paix mal
d'avis de paix bordurie par des bordures
ip syldavie jeu la combinaison des deux
graphiques et là ils sont positionnés
pour moment côte à côte
si je me souviens je crois qu'on peut
leur mettre une étiquette
alors est ce que c'est ça bordurie
galles non à ma gauche on peut que je me
souvienne des avoirs supposons que je
fasse la même chose et que je rajoute la
baisse égale bordurie sylda lui on
rajoute
coup une étiquette avec le donc du coup
ça vous permet de les mettre l'un contre
de nommer les graphiques à la volée une
autre possibilité aurait été de leur
donner un titre en amont puisque je peux
aussi faire quelque chose d'un peu
différent qui serait un peu plus propre
qui serait de mettre un title c'est à
dire ici je prends mon graphique
bordurie et je rajoute un titre bordurie
et ici je trouve affecté la vie et je
fais j'ai title si davie qui fait
plus propre parce que du coup les
graphiques seront des cendres ont
dessiné un peu la rente ou de l'autre
maintenant qu'il faut retenir aussi
c'est que je pourrais avoir envie de les
mettre sur une seule colonne et dans les
paramètres de pelote grid
nous avons entre autres deux paramètres
on va regarder l'aide de pelote grid ont
notamment and go et enhco donc à nouveau
et m comme ça permet de dire quel est le
nombre de lignes le nombre de colonnes
toulon veut donc si je fais elle colle
égal 1
ça veut dire je veux que mes graphiques
soit mise sur une seule ligne une seule
colonne et donc du coup je tiens bien
mais mes deux graphiques il en tue de
l'autre ce qui est intéressant c'est que
je peux faire ça aussi avec des
graphiques qui ne sont pas forcés qui ne
se ressemblent pas du tout je pourrais
dire que là je vais mettre mon autre
graphique qu'on a créé et qui était un
des moyens je crois et
là du coup je présente deux graphiques
qui sont différents l'un au dessus de
l'autre ce qu'on voit ici c'est que du
coup les les bordures là ne sont pas
alignés alors là c'est pas forcément
dérangeant mais si jamais je le faisais
avec on va dire p bordurie je reprenais
paix syldavie plus lee jones m
non je vais mettre un plutôt un jeu y
lab
vous voyez
physique sauf que mon graphique d'en bas
il ya un titre sur l'axé des x y et donc
du coup je ne peux plus aligné mais nous
a fait que sont pas parfaitement alignée
au niveau des axes et ça normalement
c'est paramétrable d'emploi de grid et
c'est alors où est ce que ça se trouve
je vais retrouver sa touche sur lot
bride à brasser avec les paramètres
aligne alors si je rajoute aligne égal
hp veut dire que je veux aligner mes
graphiques alors h pour l'horizontale v
pour le vertical et du coup les deux
graphiques monteiro dimensionné pour
prier que les deux axes ici soit
parfaitement alignés un donc là comme il
y avait une étiquette un petit peu plus
large
il a été séparé je vous renvoie pour
aller un peu plus loin sur les exemples
que vous aurez sur sur chapitre
analyseur la voyez quand on combine de
plusieurs graphiques ensemble on peut
aligner mais on peut aussi indiquer des
et là je les ai mis les cartes
graphiques qui sont alignés
on a du coup deux lignes de colonnes et
vous avez le paramètre well right qui
permet de dire les auteurs relative et
honda première ligne elle a une hauteur
de 2 la deuxième une autre relative de 1
et donc on peut jongler sur des auteurs
voire des larges et où des nageurs
relative
oui je vous invite aussi à voir enfin ce
dernier élément
supposons bousillé trois graphiques
d'accord qui ont la même légende de base
vous pouvez vous faites vos graphiques
vous supprimez la vous récupérez avec la
fonction gates legends la légende du
graphique vous représentez vos
graphiques ensuite séparément et enfin
vous faites un graphique avec
ou votre légende devient un trafic à
part je vais vous faire l'exemple ici
donc je vais faire claude ce weed on va
représenter paix hors du riz je vais
rajouter plus m
legends les djeunes positions' ou sa
position légale donne ça la retirera je
vais reprendre la même chose pour le
graphique de la cl dalli donc là on
sic avec un appuyer des jambes est ce
que je vais faire je vais représenter en
plus la légende du graphique de la
bordurie et donc là je vais faire guette
legends est borduré qui en fait me
permet de tenir un graphique qui ne
contient qu'une légende mais du coup là
je présente trois éléments les uns par
rapport aux autres
et du coup j'ai bien une légende commune
qui représentez ici
retenez en tout cas que il est possible
de combiner du coup différents types de
graphiques de manière avancés avec
produits de carreaux pelote qui a
vraiment moyen de faire des combinés de
graphiques
je pense qu'on a faits voilà pour assez
large de possibilités envisageables
autour des graphiques on en verra
d'autres probablement lorsque lorsque
lors des prochaines séances sur des cas
concrets on va aussi encore faire des
graphiques parce que c'est un des outils
essentiels de l'analyse voilà on reverra
des exemples n'hésitez pas à revenir
ponctuellement à ces différents éléments
là à retourner regarder un peu les codes
ou les chapitres à l'occasion en tout
cas je vous souhaite une très bonne
continuation et puis à très bientôt pour
un nouvel webinaire à très bientôt
merci